plus flippant que compte du ring plus
sanglant que cannibal holocaust
plus réaliste que the walking dead en a
marre des clichés des zombies genre
c'est super réducteur vampires en toute
intimité
ce qui est très compliqué dans le zombie
sme c'est d'entretenir une relation
familiale pour et un travail de partir
en vacances
le 30 octobre avant icinéma
exclusivement sur vos services de vidéo
à la demande
c'est bizarre on dirait que ça sans
humain un an
plus sensationnel que gravity plus
hallucinant que interstellar
plus violent que fight club vampires en
toute intimité
non
en relais du tri chez bree
maintenant la parade mawashi et et
coucou ouais le 30 octobre avant icinéma
exclusivement sur vos services de vidéo
à la demande